[Music]
on this Wednesday night an apology on
behalf of parliament this was deeply
embarrassing I would like to present
unreserved apologies that the Prime
Minister said and why the opposition
still claims it's his fault
the catering company at the center of an
E coli outbreak in Calgary charged with
bylaw infractions our goal is to develop
a system that is stronger and safer
safer plus the source is likely the
meatloaf as parents suspected wedding
nightmare the investigation and
Devastation after a fire kills more than
100 in Iraq
and a hint of smoke how Canadian
winemakers are adapting to extreme
weather the industry has to be more
resilient
plus Commander bites again the training
Mission taking shape in the White House
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
the Prime Minister has offered what he
calls parliament's unreserved apologies
to the world for recognizing a Ukrainian
man who fought with a Nazi unit during
the second world war yarislav hunka was
invited by the speaker of the house to
be in the gallery when Ukraine's
president addressed Parliament last week
politicians of all Stripes gave him a
standing ovation
this was a mistake that has deeply
embarrassed Parliament and Canada
it was a horrendous violation of the
memory of the millions of people who
died in the Holocaust and it was deeply
deeply painful
the speaker Anthony Rhoda has since
resigned and takes sole responsibility
for inviting Hanka Trudeau said today
everyone who applauded the 98 year old
regrets what happened but the whole
episode is still being used by critics
of the liberal government and of Canada
to go on the attack Mackenzie gray has
our top story tonight
foreign
Ovation to a Nazi veteran the Prime
Minister repented on behalf of all of us
in this house I would like to present
reserved apologies for what took place
on Friday and to president zielinski and
the Ukrainian delegation for the
position they were put in but
apologizing for all MPS not the right
tone for the conservatives this prime
minister allowed for a Monumental
unprecedented and Global shame to unfold
in this chamber will he take personal
responsibility for this shame and
personally apologize on behalf of
himself the leader of the opposition
knows that not one parliamentarian was
aware but the truth does not matter to
this leader the opposition the speaker
is allowed to invite whoever they want
to Parliament without any oversight
including from the Prime Minister even
if that guest is a man who fought in a
Nazi division he's a Ukrainian hero a
Canadian hero Anthony wrote it didn't
know Yara slap honka had ties to the
Nazis when he made those comments but
they forced him to resign as speaker and
the prime minister to apologize those
actions coming too late for Jewish
groups what took so long it clearly was
a terrible error you know these are
people who swore personally allegiances
to Adolf Hitler a day after wrote his
president Nation the race to replace him
is already underway I let my name stand
and along with some really other great
candidates in Parliament Quebec MP Greg
Fergus the first liberal to announce
he'd like the prestigious job
joined by current Deputy speaker and
conservative MP Chris dontrema I think
there has to be some more decorum in the
in in the house more respect for one
another the vote to officially replace
Rhoda is speaker is likely to take place
next Tuesday which will give the weekend
for candidates to work behind the scenes
and Lobby fellow MPS to vote them into
one of ottawa's most important jobs
Donna there's an update on that E coli
outbreak at daycares in Calgary more
than three weeks after it was first
declared the medical health Officer says
the likely source is as parents
suspected the meatloaf it made hundreds
of children sick there were 351 lab
confirmed cases and 37 cases of
secondary E coli infection we also
learned today the catering company that
provided the meals was operating without
a proper business license the City of
Calgary is now charging that company
these families have endured the agony of
watching their children suffer from the
battle against E coli it should have
been prevented and we know as a
government that we must take action to
ensure that this never happens again
there are no new cases but four children
are still in the hospital the province
says it's created a review panel to look
at what went wrong though as Heather
urich's West explains it could be a long
time before there are any answers
go go back to being the bundle of energy
you'd expect from a four-year-old
Lachlan is still spending his days at
home nearly a month after a meal
provided by his daycare made him
incredibly sick we no longer have um my
son in in daycare so
there's a lot of um burning the kennel
at both ends as one of the hundreds of
families affected by what has become the
largest outbreak of E coli traced back
to a single food source McDonald is
anxious to ensure this doesn't happen
again investigators now say the likely
source of the outbreak was Meatloaf
distributed by the fueling mines
catering kitchen a kitchen that's now
been charged by the City of Calgary for
operating without a proper business
license when they moved to the business
model of catering for outside
day centers daycare centers that's
that's when the Food Service license
would be required
if convicted the kitchen could face a
fine of up to 120 thousand dollars I
just wonder like how do these things get
discovered if not for an E coli outbreak
like who is who's looking at kitchens
and licenses and and keeping keeping
companies and organizations accountable
for the legislative that we already have
in place to keep people safe the kitchen
had been inspected by public health
officials multiple times earlier this
year with a number of violations flagged
each time Alberta Health Services last
inspection in April ultimately gave
fueling mines the green light to operate
though after that there was no follow-up
inspection until September after kids
started getting sick our goal is to
develop a system that is stronger and
safer safer and one that every parent
can trust but short of a full public
inquiry the province has announced an
independent third party review welcome
news to parents like McDonald as they
look for answers and do what they can to
recover and move on Heather York's West
Global News Calgary
in the U.S American Regulators have
launched a landmark lawsuit against
Amazon the Federal Trade Commission
along with 17 states are suing Amazon
alleging its Monopoly means consumers
get worse deals as tariya isri reports
it accuses the trillion dollar company
of using its dominance to squeeze out
other retailers and create artificially
high prices
this Ottawa Bookstore sells thousands of
titles including how to resist Amazon
and why I think that they should be
challenged in in their you know in their
practices and uh they're big enough that
they have so much influence and so much
reach the U.S Federal Trade Commission
and 17 states have launched a lawsuit
accusing the company of exploiting its
monopolies in ways that enrich Amazon
but harm its customers the woman leading
the charge is FTC chairlena Khan Who
Rose to fame as a Yale law student with
a paper about how antitrust laws have
failed to reign in Amazon we think that
there is enormous urgency here in terms
of the harms that the American public is
facing the lawsuit alleges consumers are
paying artificially higher prices
because of tactics that make it
impossible for Rivals to compete like
blocking Merchants from selling their
products for less and forcing them to
use and pay for Amazon's delivery
services
Jeff Bezos started the company in his
garage in 1994 selling books the most
important thing is to be customer
obsessed
it's since become the everything store
now worth a whopping 1.3 trillion
dollars U.S in the states there's been a
trend over the last few years to go
after
um the term big Tech and so I think this
is just the next iteration Amazon says
Federal Trade Regulators have their
facts wrong and that the ftc's focus has
radically departed from its mission of
protecting consumers and competition
the FTC is asking the court to consider
forcing Amazon to sell its assets the
appetite for
for breaking up companies that make our
lives easier and cheaper is low Canada's
competition Bureau declined to comment
when asked whether a similar
investigation is underway here but
Canadian Regulators are likely following
this lawsuit very closely as Ottawa like
Washington takes a closer look at how
big Tech is monopolizing so much of our
lives
Global News Ottawa
a landmark lawsuit is underway in Europe
over the future impact of the climate
crisis six young people from Portugal
are taking 32 countries to the European
Court of Human Rights they accuse the
countries of failing to take quick
enough action to protect them from
climate change the lawsuit is the first
of its kind and adds to the pressure on
governments to accelerate plans to cut
greenhouse gas emissions as Eric
Sorensen reports the stakes are high
on a beach in Portugal two young people
explained why they're taking 32 European
governments to court I'm
waves and extreme drought are more
frequent in Portugal these days as Andre
and Sophia added we thought it is now or
never to speak up they are Claudia
Katarina Martine today six young
Portuguese had their day in court
alleging that governments across Europe
are violating their human rights doing
too little to protect them from climate
change
today's case is about the young
it is about the price that they are
paying for the failure of states to
tackle the climate emergency the
argument is that young people in
particular face a future of hardship
Rising heat and air pollution means less
time spent out the doors
infringing on children's human rights to
education to play and to engage in
recreational activities European
government lawyers say they accept the
impacts of climate change but that these
cases should be heard in National courts
first it is a new legal Frontier in the
battle to address climate change and
force governments around the world to do
more to protect young Generations who
don't have the power to protect
themselves a similar case is ongoing in
this country four years ago 15 young
people filed a challenge in BC to put
the federal government on trial for
what's facing the Next Generation they
are already being harmed by climate
change and the federal government
therefore is violating their rights to
life liberty and security that case has
found its way to the federal court of
appeal in Montana a judge ruled last
month in favor of young people who'd
accuse the state of violating their
rights by promoting fossil fuels it's
being appealed but it demonstrates that
young people see the courts as a
mechanism to force governments to do
more it's allowing young people to have
a voice and start calling out the
injustices that are facing their
generation if the case brought by young
people in Europe is upheld it could lead
to National courts ordering governments
to act more quickly to curb emissions a
decision there is expected next year
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
climate change is also threatening the
wine industry the risk and the intensity
of wildfires is on the rise several BC
wineries suffered over this summer which
was the worst Wildfire season on record
Nito Garcia visited one of the
province's hardest hit wineries to look
at how they're being forced to evolve
grapes from Vineyards in BC's Okanagan
Valley are known for making wines with
hints of pear nectarine and apple but
what about notes of wildfire
smoke is is a factor in a vintage but it
doesn't necessarily mean that oh there
was a fire the you know the vintages
were on winemakers are learning to
mitigate the issue of so-called smoke
taint using wine making and harvesting
techniques we just have to manage that
differently so the industry has to be
more resilient and look at Innovation
researchers at UBC Okanagan say 2003 was
the first major instance of smoke
profoundly affecting wine quality now
there's a better understanding of how
smoke interacts with a grape how to
protect ripening crops and even using
smoke to benefit certain varietals we
can harness that knowledge potentially
to also guide an understanding of how
the environment might enhance or make
more desirable Aromas in in BC wines
as the Region's wildfires rage on Tony
Stewart says the damage is done
including through travel restrictions
which crippled tourism it's probably one
of the most significant events that
we've had to deal with when you look at
like just burnt all the way around
actually came right through the fence on
this side so you know probably about
four rows have been either completely
destroyed or very badly damaged Niche
Winery is among the Region's hardest hit
they've been closed for nearly a month
and a half all of our crop has been
consumed by wildlife and so we've lost
the fence we've lost the crop we lost an
equipment shed that housed some of our
Harvest equipment we've spent our adult
lives building this dream so to see it
under threat in that kind of way is
really was distressing for Stuart he
says there's reason for optimism in the
face of the growing threat of more
frequent extreme weather events and
climate change and he points to the
little-known history of champagne as why
the wine industry its history is built
on this I mean we don't have we're
drinking champagne today because of a
event in Europe in the late 1600s which
was referred to as the mini ice age he
wonders what could be Brewing right now
that could be the next great Innovation
for wine lovers and an increasingly
weather challenged industry
Global News West Kelowna BC
a celebration Up in Flames in seconds
coming up how a fire at an Iraqi wedding
left more than 100 dead
the former State minister of
nagorno-karabakh has been arrested by
Azerbaijan he was detained as he tried
to cross into Armenia Azerbaijan
launched an offensive last week in hopes
of reintegrating the region thousands of
refugees from nagorno-karabakh have been
fleeing the territory since the
offensive began triggering a
humanitarian crisis nagorno-karabakh is
internationally recognized as part of
Azerbaijan but is populated by mostly
ethnic Armenians the president of Iraq
has ordered an investigation into a
terrible fire at a wedding celebration
more than 100 people were killed at
least 150 others injured when the
banquet hall they were in went up in
Flames it happened in Nineveh in
Northern Iraq near mosul as Mike
Armstrong explains it took just seconds
for the celebration to turn into a
tragedy and a warning some of the
details in his story are disturbing
[Music]
trouble
according to witnesses as many as a
thousand people were packed into this
Hall a building with only three exits
the Survivor from a stretcher says the
bride and groom had just started their
first dance when the chaos began
slow they were slow dancing when the
fire started she says video on social
media appears to show pyrotechnics being
shot off in the hall and decorations
Catching Fire
this man says suddenly the entire
ceiling was in flames and burning
material was falling on people
according to authorities the hall was
built with prefabricated panels that
were highly flammable and against the
Safety Code they were also plastic and
released toxic gases as they burned
this military official says nine people
from the Halls Administration have been
arrested they're still looking for
others meantime many families have been
left looking for loved ones nearby
hospitals were overwhelmed and victims
ended up in facilities all over the
region as for the dead about 30 bodies
have been identified but most are so
badly burned it'll take DNA testing for
identification
and this family went to the site they
found only the clothes their mother was
wearing she's still missing as are in
some cases entire families
there are reports the bride and groom
were able to escape Mike Armstrong
Global News
[Music]
Rich tonight
60 million well well I first of all I'd
take 10 of that and I donate it to my
church if I won the lottery tonight I'd
probably build a indoor wave pool in
Regina so we could surf in Regina
all dream right well some someone is
going to win big tonight the Lotto 649
jackpot is a record 68 68 million
dollars break
previous record of 64 million and this
is the first time that all 29 white
balls have been drawn before the gold
ball meaning tonight's draw is
guaranteed to feature a maximum gold
Ball jackpot of a cool 68 million
Canada's women's soccer team officially
punched its ticket to next year's
Olympics in Paris where they'll have the
opportunity to defend their Olympic
title across Canada have done it the
women beat Jamaica 2-1 in their
qualifier in Toronto on Tuesday that win
serves as a high point for the squad
after they fail to advance from the
group stage at the FIFA Women's World
Cup earlier this year
a note about some changes at Global News
a program I hosted called the new
reality is ending
the television news magazine series
premiered on global in 2020 at the start
of the pandemic a challenging time in
all our lives that required information
insight and in-depth discussion the
program carried on beyond that exploring
broader topics about scientific medical
and cultural advancements in Canada and
the world in what chorus calls a
business decision the program will not
be renewed for 2024 the final Eight
Episodes will Air this fall
he hasn't been a good boy next weather
Biden family dog might need a shorter
leash
[Music]
being president of the United States
comes with all kinds of challenges and
for President Joe Biden right now that
includes dealing with his dog Commander
the family's German Shepherd has made
the news again for biting another secret
service agent at the White House
Brittany Rosen looks at why the
presidential pup is in the doghouse hey
pal the phrase a dog is a man's best
friend certainly Rings true for
President Biden and Commander however
the two-year-old German Shepherd has had
a rough time warming up to Biden's
closest colleagues they have been
partnering with the Secret Service and
executive resident staff on additional
leashing protocols and training
Commander has nipped 11 Secret Service
agents since last October even sending
one to hospital the latest incident
unfolding Monday at the White House as a
fellow dog owner you know we want people
to like dogs and want to have dogs
around and I think part of that is like
not having your dog biting people
Commander isn't the first privileged pet
to attack the UK prime minister's feline
Larry the cat also made headlines after
clawing at a journalist good good Gunner
sit good boy Scott dancer has trained
thousands of dogs including this
nine-year-old German Shepherd Gunner is
it a matter of the dog is being
overprotective of Biden does it sense
some sort of threat in the air why does
this keep happening so it sounds like
there's a lot of hustle and bustle going
on at the White House dancer says
Commander is likely under a great deal
of stress constantly seeing a host of
unfamiliar faces the solution he says is
more socialization we need to set them
up for success by meeting new people by
kind of building a language between you
and the dog in order to communicate what
you expect from them dancer says with
the proper training a dog like Gunner or
even Commander could learn to stop
biting within weeks a good boy he adds
it would be a positive step in the right
direction Brittany Rosen Global News
Washington good and that is global
national for this Wednesday I'm Donna
Friesen tonight's your Canada is Shoal
Harbor in clarinville Newfoundland and
Labrador we'd love to see your Canada
please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you